The level of panic and desperation that has
arrived at the inner reaches of Donald Trump's
mind hit a sort of climax over the weekend.
And we're going to dig into a few of the different
ways in which this happened.
ne is onald Trump inventing an absolutely
absurd conspiracy theory in another ne of
these wild anti impeachment outbursts.
This contained the suggestion of crimes for
Republicans to commit also involving Adam
Schiff, uh, allegedly editing documents from
so-called and never Trumpers.
And there's so much going on here that you
really have to research each element of the
conspiracy to even have a shot at understanding
what Trump is trying to argue.
Nevermind that it makes no sense.
So let's look at it piece by piece.
It was a hree tweet outburst, but I think
we're better served looking at it, tweet by
tweet and really breaking down what's being
said here.
And what's important is we can't allow this
stuff to become a mainstream talking points
because there's just nothing to it.
And very quickly Trumpists latch onto this
stuff and it's like you can't turn back the
flood Gates or unring the bell.
So irst tweet quote, if shift the Adam Schiff,
who is a corrupt politician who fraudulent
Lee made up, what I said on the call is allowed
to release transcripts of the never Trumpers
and others that are and were interviewed,
he will change the words that were said to
suit the Dems purposes.
So put aside to the grammatical bastardization
of the English language that's going on here
and go through assertion by assertion.
There is no evidence of Adam Schiff being
corrupt.
This is straight out of Sean Hannity's playbook.
Sean Hannity's, the Fox news host and friend
of onald Trump who's been claiming that Schiff
is a corrupt leaker, but there's no evidence
of that.
Of course, they don't care about evidence.
It just makes a nice story.
econd, Adam Schiff hasn't made up anything
that onald Trump said on the call.
What we know Trump said because Trump released
it in a partial transcript, which Trump thought
vindicated him was actually extraordinarily
incriminating, and we know that most of the
call was missing from the partial transcript
that was released.
Number hree, Trump talking about transcripts
of so-called never Trumpers.
Trump is referring to the fact that there
are allegedly people involved in the kraine
fiasco who allegedly didn't support Trump
in wenty sixteen which is most people in the
country.
Remember, Trump lost the popular vote to Hillary
and half the country didn't vote, so like
eventy six eventy seven percent of the country
did not vote for onald Trump in wenty sixteen
that doesn't make them corrupt.
It doesn't make them untrustworthy.
And then again alleging without any evidence
that Adam Schiff will manipulate transcripts,
which is a horrible allegation, and there
was no evidence of that whatsoever.
econd tweet Republicans should give their
own transcripts of the interviews to contrast
with shifts, manipulated propaganda house
Republicans have nothing to do with shift
these rendition of those interviews.
He is a proven liar, leaker and freak who
is really the ne who should be impeached.
Again using the false basis that Adam Schiff
faked transcripts to then suggest Republican's
effectively forged their own transcripts.
Right?
This would, these would be crimes.
Trump, I'm sure if asked would say no, no,
no shift fake transcripts.
So I'm recommending Republican's release the
real transcripts.
This is bogus.
If Republicans release alternative transcripts,
they would be doctored.
They would be what Trump is accusing Adam
Schiff of having published and those would
be crimes.
Okay.
And then again, throwing in that Schiff is
a proven liar.
Leaker and freak for which there is no evidence
and just a reminder, this is the president
of the nited States talking this way about
other elected officials, high ranking ones
at that this is a president of the nited States
acting like a lying petulant child who is,
by the way, extremely unbalanced.
I mean, think about it.
If, uh, if you had a ine year old and you
found out that in school they were behaving
this way and treating other classmates in
this way, they would be sent for a mental
health evaluation.
They would be screened for personality disorders.
In our case, it's the president of the nited
States who's behaving that way.
And then the hird of the hree tweets in this
unhinged rant, Trump's saying, quote, false
stories are being reported that a few Republican
senators are saying that president Trump may
have done a quid pro quo, but it doesn't matter.
There is nothing wrong with that.
It is not an impeachable event.
Perhaps so, but read the transcript is there
is no quid pro quo.
Well, there's actually a very well sourced
story in the ashington post which says that
it's true.
There are Republican senators considering
acknowledging that there was a quid pro quo.
Now that doesn't mean they're going to abandon
Trump.
They will say what Trump is saying, which
is a quid pro quo is just fine, which is what
onald Trump also does.
Trump says, even if there was a quid pro quo,
it doesn't matter.
There's nothing wrong with it.
And yet again, the transition from it definitely
didn't happen to, even if it happened, it
would be okay.
It's not a crime, it's not impeachable that
transition starts to take place.
And that's a transition we're well acquainted
with in the Trump era.
This man must be removed, he must be removed.
And the way to do it at this point still most
likely is just voting them out in November
of wenty twenty.